so uh listen there are people who
would feel a sense of satisfaction from
what i'm about to play for you
i feel no satisfaction whatsoever i i
actually feel
despair when i see the video i'm about
to play for
you because it's emblematic of so much
of what's wrong
with our country this is an example
of yet again another republican
who was very laissez faire about kovid
and stood behind trump
literally and figuratively with no mask
defending everything trump was doing
praising trump
until he got coronavirus himself and i'm
talking about former new jersey
republican
governor chris christie who ended up
after not wearing a mask at the white
house at a super spreader event
chris christie ended up in a hospital
icu
with covid and now chris christie is in
a national ad defiantly
and powerfully advocating for mask
wearing
so take a look at the ad here is chris
christie specifically with a message
to those refusing to wear a mask this
message isn't for everyone
it's for all those people who refuse to
wear a mask
you know lying in isolation in icu for
seven days
i thought about how wrong i was to
remove my mask at the white house
today i think about how wrong it is to
let mask wearing divide us
especially as we now know you're twice
as likely to get covert 19
if you don't wear a mask because if you
don't do the right thing
we could all end up on the wrong side of
history
please wear a mask so chris christie
says
as we now know but we've known this for
months
so okay it's true we maybe didn't know
in february and march
about masks but chris christie got
covered a couple months ago
we knew for six months at that point
about the importance of wearing masks
and not doing indoor events everything
that chris christie participated in
which likely
got him the virus so i get it on the one
hand good for chris christie
and i see lots of leftists retweeting
this ad on twitter
okay but this goes back to one of the
real tragedies
of the republican party and reactionary
right-wing thinking in the united states
this is not new if you've been watching
the show listening for a while you've
heard me say this before
his view changed only because he got the
virus
and he may only be willing to do this ad
because ultimately donald trump already
lost and he knows that there's
less of a political risk to doing it
this is just like the homophobic
republican
who spends 20 years fighting against gay
rights and then finds out their kid is
gay and has an awakening
okay it's great when someone comes
around to the correct position there's
no doubt about it
but why does it have to happen only when
you
uh uh recognize that it affects you
personally
it only happens when you have a kid
or or what you right we've talked about
the homophobic example
can't you simply empathize with the
parent of the gay kid
who sees you fighting against gay rights
and and have that same awakening
couldn't chris christie have understood
the importance of masks without ending
up in the icu personally
after taking his mask off at the white
house why does it take
being in an icu with coronavirus
to understand what we should be doing do
you think that there's something
um physiological going on where some of
us
are able to say hey you know what i
didn't have covet that i know of
in fact maybe i did actually back back
in april but that's a different story
i'm not aware that i certainly had it
and if i did i didn't end up in
in the icu but i still wear a mask
and don't do indoor gatherings and so on
and so forth
because i understand that even if it
didn't happen to me it's happening to
other people
why is it that the republicans seem
unable to do it
i i don't know the answer i'm genuinely
asking it when we
see a republican show a shred
of humanity and empathy it's because
they
or someone in their family had something
happened to them and until that point
they don't seem to care
chris christie is absolutely correct and
if this video that he did if this ad he
did
convinces someone to wear a mask who
hasn't been all power to chris christie
but this is pathetic that this is what
it took
for him to come to this conclusion if
he's pushing deniers to act
responsibly thank you chris fantastic
but why did it take until almost a year
into the pandemic
if we had had more prominent republicans
saying these things in march
instead of 15 cases will soon be zero
it's like a flu
we're handling it perfectly we would be
much better off right now
i prefer public servants who can
see beyond how something affects them
personally
and understand how things affect other
people
and society at large so yeah
i i know that there are leftists who are
merely praising chris christie and
that's fine and it's fine to amplify the
message
but this is a microcosm this is
emblematic
of the lack of or inability to
experience
empathy that seems to be
an epidemic in and of itself among the
american rights
and uh i i i think we can leave it there
but i'm curious to hear from you we'll
we'll have more on this as well as the
chris christie clip
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman show you
can also follow me on instagram at
david.pacman
i've gotten so it's funny i will do
something so random
and hear from 500 people and i i i don't
always understand the logic i posted
like a 10 second video on my instagram
which is david.pakman
of me out in a rainstorm and my umbrella
reversing and i'm kind of i'm
essentially battling the umbrella and
trying to get it under control like a
wild stallion that hasn't yet
uh uh been saddled and uh i i must have
gotten four or 500 different messages
about this silly little video so anyway
if you want a break from the tragedy
and just want pure comedy follow me at
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
i've so much more to talk about today
glad you're with us you may not have
known this but when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i asked them to be a sponsor
because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat-felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you fifteen percent off your first
order if you use the coupon code pacman
at checkout